the Department of Homeland Security is
looking to increase its monitoring of
Facebook and to do something like
Palantir is the key to stopping major
terrorist attacks these are profile
based automated pre-crime suspicion
generating mechanisms Precog see the
future and they're never wrong I would
compare artificial intelligence of
machine learning to the advent of
electricity it looks to us like a black
box the intelligence community is
focused on getting intelligence wherever
it can by any means possible you're just
told sorry you can't go there you can't
do that we all leave digital trails
behind us as we journey through the
world and rapid advancements in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning technology have allowed
corporations and governments to build
ever more precise tools to analyze that
data discover patterns and even predict
behavior I think one of the things that
were in the process of grappling with as
a society is what is this technology
mean what does it do I would compare
artificial intelligence and machine
learning to the advent of electricity so
imagine that you just heard about this
magical thing called electricity but
there are bad things you can do with
electricity you can put people in an
electric chair and I use it for capital
punishment those are things I'm gonna
have to work through this technologies
what are those concerns
some privacy experts however worried
that handing this powerful technology
over to opaque government agencies is
laying the groundwork for a total police
state the Berlin wall wasn't actually
built in a day it was built quickly but
the checkpoints already existed it's
just that people were accustomed to
passing from the American zone to the
Soviet zone to the French zone and what
changed on the day was that all of a
sudden the turnstile didn't lift you
weren't allowed through the checkpoint
then the wall was built in but in
building the checkpoints in building the
control mechanisms we're already putting
in place the infrastructure for those
who will abuse them in the future
some Silicon Valley companies have been
building artificially intelligence
surveillance tools for the deep state
that helped government agents make sense
of massive amounts of information
scattered across several databases and
to discover patterns that might
otherwise be hidden
they're called threat intelligence firms
and one of the biggest and the business
is named Palantir one of the ways that
people use the term threat intelligence
is in terms of open source intelligence
gathering information about national
security or other threats just by
essentially reading the news reading
twitter companies like Palantir can run
artificial intelligences that can read a
lot more of Twitter than any one person
or even a team of people could possibly
think of doing Palantir received an
early two million dollar investment from
in-q-tel the venture capital arm of the
CIA but Palantir x' biggest early funder
was PayPal found her Facebook board
member and Trump supporter Peter teal
who invested thirty million dollars in
the company which now has a twenty
billion dollar valuation something like
Palantir is the key to stopping major
terrorist attacks I don't think we're
gonna do it by projecting military force
throughout the world we will do it by
uncovering these conspiracies before
they come together the United States has
conducted an operation that killed Osama
bin Laden the leader of al-qaeda
journalist Mark Bowden reported in 2012
that the hunt for bin Laden drew on an
unfathomably rich database and after the
government failed to parse the data on
its own
Palantir developed a product that
actually deserves the popular
designation killer app and teal and
outspoken libertarian told Fortune
magazine he hopes his technology will
actually help protect the Civil
Liberties of Americans because given the
massive amounts of Americans data the
government takes in if we could help
them make sense of data they could end
indiscriminate surveillance we're not
creating a technology that's this black
box algorithmic engine that you just
throw data into it and it spits out an
answer to you but privacy experts worry
that the secrecy around some of Palantir
contracts with the Department of
Homeland Security are eroding civil
liberties Palin tears tools in their
sophistication and complexity and their
algorithmic rule sets enable the
transition from this watching role to a
proactive predictive policing role they
are the supposed precogs precogs see the
future and they're never Roe but it's
not the future if you stop there's not a
fundamental paradox the movie Minority
Report famously portrayed a society
where police harnessed the power of
psychic precogs
to arrest people for crimes before they
are ever actually committed a 2012
Department of Homeland Security report
boasts that Palin tears tech can be used
to predict future activities so in
moving down that path of pre-crime
profiling we're accepting that it is
legitimate to impose consequences based
on robotic precogs conclusions about
what you're likely to do in the future
it's mr. order personal intelligence and
we think about Skynet and Hal for 2001 a
lot of times the actual technical
reality is much more mundane and less
exciting we may be looking at things
that are for the AI simply understanding
what humans may intuitively get if you
drop a pen on the floor you're likely to
bend over and pick it up right or types
of predictions it might be in the
aggregate right so for an aggregate
population that undertakes certain
behaviors some percentage of them are
likely to do X Y or Z
the time is overdue to develop a new
screening test for the threats we face
today I call it extreme vetting when the
Trump administration talks about extreme
betting they the Palantir stools and the
decisions based on them are what they're
talking about Palantir landed a major
government contract in 2014 when the
Obama administration approved a 40 1.6
million dollar deal with Immigration and
Customs Enforcement to set up an
algorithmic profiling system how many
government contracts do you currently
hold today most of our contracts have
massive clauses in them saying we can't
we can't disclose the full extent of
Palantir x' federal contracts remains
unknown but under the trump
administration the company has created a
profiling system for border patrol and a
former Palantir lobbyist serves in the
pentagon as deputy chief of staff to
defense secretary James Madison is from
Palantir declined to participate in this
video but the company website assures
visitors that there is oversight from
Palantir x' Council on privacy and civil
liberties Palantir is as opaque today as
they were when they were founded when
other organizations have filed FOIA
requests seeking information about it
they're almost uniformly denied it looks
to us like a black box and without being
inside Palantir it's hard to say exactly
how it works the Department of Homeland
Security has only released highly
redacted materials about these systems
arguing in court that the algorithms
must stay secret in order to remain
effective one of the challenges in a lot
of intelligence work is that oftentimes
the nature of the work is that if you
explained publicly exactly what you're
doing and how you're collecting
information on whether it's a terrorist
or another government you spoil that
source of information when the
government is telling judges whose role
is to review and approve these things
trust us but don't actually look at what
we're doing don't look behind the
curtain that should be a red flag that
something wrong is going on behind the
curtain and that we need to look more
closely at it enemies of freedom
an act of war against our country what
we've seen since 9/11 is the emergence
of a homeland security industrial
complex that now rivals in its lobbying
power and its influence in Washington
the military-industrial complex but I
think the existence of a homeland
security industrial complex has a force
in Washington regardless of which party
is in power has been largely
unrecognized
because of the secrecy around the
technology it's hard to know to what
degree the federal government has
deployed it not only against immigrants
and refugees but against American
citizens we do know post 9/11 that
information sharing between foreign
intelligence agencies and domestic law
enforcement has become routine once
these tools are built the mission creep
is extremely rapid once the NSA built a
tool to try and find terrorists phone
calls it was almost immediately used by
DEA to find street-level drug criminals
if ice builds a tool using Palantir
technology we can be certain that that
tool will be used to whatever a
government customer wants to do the real
question is what do we do with the
technology right who's using it for what
purpose is and under what kinds of
safeguards particularly talking with the
government what are the checks and
balances in place but there's no
technology that is just inherently good
or inherently bad it's about how we're
using it and to what ends I don't think
it's inevitable that the government is
going to adopt this kind of technology
any more than it's inevitable that we're
going to have a regime where you have to
show your papers everywhere you go or
where there are virtual checkpoints
everywhere in your facial image and it's
template is a virtual key that's vetted
every time you walk down the street the
situation is bad it's going to take
significant change and significant
popular resistance and pushback
you
[Music]
you